foreign
from YouTube David has something for us
I have loads of nice clothes but I end
up wearing my old clothes instead
because I'm scared of ruining the new
ones it's always on my mind when I try
to put them on and it's starting to
impact my mental health how do I get rid
of all the old things and start wearing
all the new things without worrying
about what happens to them I'm thinking
about fear here because essentially
you're afraid of something happening to
these new nice clothes right and I get
that I've owned something that I put in
my closet and I'll try it on and I'm
like oh but I don't want to wrinkle it
up it's like well wait a minute fear is
merely a byproduct of the ego right and
so the ego is what telling me a story
about the thing it's telling me to be
afraid let's talk about what the
antidote to fear is real quick the
antidote to fear is joy
and joy is one of those things that we
we know it when it's there
but I don't think we really understand
it so let's do an etymology lesson real
quick the the Greek word for joy is
Cairo which comes from the root caress
which means gift
and so in a way when we are joyous we're
experiencing a gift a gift of life or
when we are being joyous we're also
giving a gift to someone else in a way
when we're doing the opposite we're
doing what we're worrying all the time
well to worry is to pray for something
bad to happen in the future and that is
what David is doing here and I'm saying
this as a warrior I am a poster child
for worry so I'm not
for I'm not standing on some sort of
Mount preaching this to you I'm making
an observation about worry whenever I
worry about something the only thing
that I can do that dissipates the worry
is to see the absurdity of the worry and
that quite often makes room for Joy
which then eliminates the fear that I'm
experiencing I'll give you an example
recently we actually had to reschedule
this podcast recording because I was
trapped in Ojai California during the
Reigns I was talking to my neighbors
they had been there for my next door
neighbor has lived in that house for 40
years and the most rain they've ever
experienced was on Monday of this week
there were 17 inches of rain at the uh
in the the mountains there at in Ojai
and you could see it was pouring our
streets were flooded the Ventura river
is not usually a river it is a riverbed
but it not only overflowed but it
clogged up the highway the reason the
101 was closed was because the Ventura
River
not just exceeded its limit but but
burst through its limits right and so
what happened of course I felt worried
oh no what happens if my house floods
hmm okay well then my house floods going
to be an inconvenience right a giant
inconvenience but do I have insurance
yes I do and so it's okay to be
concerned about these things the
concerns Point toward okay what caution
do I need to have what makes sense to
have flood insurance makes sense to have
homeowners insurance
but if my house were to flood if my
house were to burn down this also
happened about a week ago I was walking
home with Bex we saw a fire in our
neighbor's yard we didn't know it was
our neighbor's yard I thought it was our
house at first and their barbecue would
caught on fire but I thought uh oh
I hope that isn't our house and I felt
worry in the moment but I realized okay
what's the worst thing that could happen
here and so
David the thing that I see here is I'm
going to ask myself what is the worst
thing that could happen I want to take
this to its Terminus because what's the
worst thing that could happen if you got
rid of the old clothes you wear the new
clothes and you don't enjoy them okay
say it out loud write it down I might
not enjoy my new clothes as much yeah
okay I'll take it even farther what if
you got rid of all the new clothes and
just kept wearing the old clothes what's
the worst thing that could happen I'd
probably have less clutter and maybe I'd
think about the things I let go of maybe
but maybe you'd also make some room
what's the worst thing that could happen
if you keep going okay
maybe I'll miss those close okay what's
the worst thing that happens then
I don't know
oh yeah
there is no worse thing that's gonna
happen here and if you take that fear
that worry to its Terminus you'll
realize
that the thing you've built up in your
head is absolutely absurd and you can
let it go because there's nothing to
actually be worried about this makes me
think about a pair of uh
um white boots that I bought in high
school
oh I forget the brand it doesn't matter
there were lugs yeah lugs that's what it
was yeah yeah I was there bro you guys
remember things for each other yeah
bright white lugs I remember that I
remember the first day of school I'm
like sporting these and my buddy comes
up to me he's like how did you get the
coolest shoes in school man I'm like
yeah thanks man I appreciate it but you
know being the messy minimalist that I
am
um I dirty them pretty quickly and it
got to a point where I'm like oh wow I
can't wear these as much as I want to
because I'm going to dirty them and uh I
found myself kind of getting stuck in
this cycle that that David's in and what
I finally accepted was is like I am not
responsible enough to have white shoes
and that's okay I'm willing to accept
that
um I'm not I don't take care of them
well enough so
um yeah I wore them
um as much as I could until you know
finally they were just I mean you know
how wide shoes get and I got rid of them
and I never bought White Shoes again
because I learned my lesson my sophomore
year of high school in Lebanon Ohio but
but David these new clothes that you
have they're going to be old close soon
I mean soon enough they'll be old
clothes so wear them while they're new
um you know I think clutter is a concept
that uh not only applies to things that
are useless but it also applies to
things that are useful in a way that
distracts from the life we really want
to live imagine if I'm addicted to a
video game and you know I play this
video game 12 hours a day and every time
I look up I think oh no that's not what
I wanted to do with my time that video
game was useful I'm using it but it's
getting in the way of what I really want
to do with my time and so it's not about
labels like is it useful or is it
useless it's about the experience of
meaning it's about that adventure of
being alive and someone else may be able
to point to my experience and say well
that's a useless thing you should get
rid of it but maybe it creates value for
me or someone may look at something else
in my life and say oh that's very
pragmatic everyone has one of those keep
it around but maybe it gets in the way
of what I want and for me it becomes
clutter you don't want a life that you
can justify by appealing to fancy labels
you want the experience of meaning
so whether you call it clutter or
someone else calls it clutter just strip
all that away and say man am I doing
what I want to do with my time and with
my energy am I experiencing the life
that I want to live am I wearing what I
want to wear or is this stuff simply
getting in the way did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free